I would like to talk today about data
validation for feature pipelines
specifically and I want to show you at
what point you can use data validation
in your feature engineering pipelines
I'll show that with the example of Great
Expectations and how you can do that
with hopsworks
so with a feature store but I will also
quickly explain the difference between
different
data validation libraries that are
available today for the python community
so let's have a look first at some
examples of ml systems and how they
often look like today or ml pipelines
let's say
um so let's say you have some data
warehouse with some transactional data
and you want to train two models a fraud
classification system for those
transaction and maybe a user
categorization system right
um so what you would do is
um you would write your feature
pipelines or your feature engineering
logic since this is a python conference
I would say you would write it using
pandas Transformations
um and then you would take this pipeline
you would generate your training data
set and train a model and then once you
have
train the model uh you go and take the
same Pipeline and deploy it somewhere
for production to compute those features
on a rolling basis for example nightly
weekly and so on
um and then serve those features somehow
to the on online serving if it's an
online model so if you get immediate
responses or if you're using a batch
style approach you would save those
features somewhere pass them to the
batch serving where the ho where the
whole data gets run through the model
and then you write out the batch
inference input output for example again
into your data warehouse as you can see
this creates this kind of spaghetti
style pipeline architecture where you
have first of all a lot of duplication
and that's
basically the first challenge
you will duplicate all the pipelines for
each model even though maybe the
features overlap to a large extent right
so for example in these two cases the
features uh transaction amount last week
last month are most likely going to show
up in both of these models right so
you're duplicating your logic
essentially and then you're furthermore
duplicating
um the logic by having those pipelines
split for training data set generation
and for the production part
um and that creates a bunch of problems
for example are these pipelines
consistent what happens if bad data has
been loaded into your data warehouse and
so on so how can we avoid that and
naturally data validation comes to mind
um and a lot of people when we talk to
them
um what we see them doing is basically
they add data validation to each of
these
um
uh pipelines right that makes sense it
to some extent and for example when you
generate the training data set
afterwards you run it through either
some data validation logic make sure
there's no null values make sure that
your features are within a certain range
for example
however again since you have this
spaghetti setup already
you're duplicating also the validation
logic right so the question is how can
we avoid that and
so we think that's actually the wrong
point to do the data validation itself
um so and there's a second problem with
that approach is that you have generated
your training data or you have loaded
your features or computed all your
features and then you do data validation
but what happens if you actually notice
at that point
um
that the data quality isn't there right
so
you have to go back to the source and
re-run everything from scratch
um trying to debug and find the problem
in the data
and basically at that point it's already
too late and your model in production uh
most likely will be broken or at least
delayed right
um so that's often what we call the
garbage in garbage out problem like at
this point if you feed any any bad data
um to the model you will get back
um bad uh predictions as well
so we think that's the wrong approach
and that that's where the feature store
comes into place and essentially a
feature store is meant to be a central
repository for all your feature data
um where you write
um data into it once and then you can
consume it from multiple models um the
same feature so basically it becomes the
centralized unit that helps you
de-duplicate your feature engineering
pipelines for example you might have
different sources so you might have your
data warehouse for which you set up a
pipeline for example to compute all
those transactional features and then
you write them into a feature group
or you for example have a Kafka stream
of data of real-time transactions for
example and you have a spark streaming
application which writes into the
feature store
and to explain a bit the abstractions in
the feature store a feature group is
then basically a grouping of features
which have been engineered uh together
in a pipeline
and the way we see it feature groups are
the API of the feature store to write
data into it and then to get the data
out of it you basically want to be able
to select depending on the model you
want to train you want to be able to
select different features from different
feature groups and that's the feature
view it doesn't duplicate any of the
data it's simply a mapping from feature
groups to a model and it allows you to
add additional Transformations which are
model specific so for example
let's say I have these transactional
features in one of my feature groups and
I want to train a model one for the us
and one for Europe or for customers in
Europe one for customers in the US
what happens in that case is that the
statistics over those features might be
completely different right because U.S
customers behave differently to European
customers
which means that the normalization is
model specific right and this is where
feature view can help you as well
it stores these Statistics over your
slice of data that you train on and then
later on when you do batch inference or
online inference we can apply the same
normalization using the same statistics
and therefore being consistent between
training data set generation and
um
production right where you where you
pull the new features from the feature
store
um and apply the same Transformations
again
and then our picture looks much simpler
and this is also where
data validation comes back into play
because now since we have a single
feature pipeline per feature group now
we can validate this um
those features in that feature group
once and then we can actually make a
decision about what do we want to do
with that data if the data validation
fails right so we can decide do we still
want to write the the data into the
feature store means it becomes available
to all the models that are using that
feature however we can raise an alert or
um yeah notify an engineer
but at the same time you could also say
like okay stop I don't want to write
this data into the feature store it's
better to use the features from last
night for my predictions than doing a
prediction
um on bad quality data or
basically leading to a model failure
because you might have a null value
somewhere and your model can't handle
that right
um so yeah and then you have the feature
views which contain all the model
specific
Transformations and from the model
feature from the feature view it's
basically the API where you read from so
you use the feature view to generate the
training data sets
and the models pull features from the
feature View
[Music]
um
while serving or in production and
basically the feature groups
um since this feature pipeline will run
periodically for like I said nightly or
weekly or as a streaming pipeline
um the data within the feature store
will be continuously evolving so it's
kind of mutable
um every time the model pulls the data
from the feature view it will get you
can request the data from a certain time
slice so for example give me the data
that has arrived within the last day or
the features that have been updated
within the last day and so on
um so let's take a closer look at how we
can put data validation there
um
so when we started out we were wondering
uh what what's available in the python
Community which libraries and what are
their advantages and
especially what are they supposed to do
and what are they not doing right
um because oftentimes yeah
um that's not clear from the beginning
um when you talk to people there's often
yeah three libraries come up the first
one is pedantic
when we look took a closer look at it
basically what we saw is that it's
actually more like a parsing library or
that does data validation but it's very
specific to classes right um to to
python classes and it uses python type
annotations to do that and that doesn't
really fit the the use case of data
engineering or or feature engineering
because we don't work more mostly with
data classes itself objects in in the
classical sense but instead we work with
data frames right
um or tables if you want to see it like
that
and if you take a closer look into
pedantic
basically it it ensures that whatever
you initialize your classes with it
the data you initialize it with adheres
to the type annotations that you gave to
that class right
however to make this applicable to data
frames and I've put some negative
examples where people have been doing
that and actually it turns out to be
very lengthy code a lot of boilerplate
code that you have to write where you
basically
map rows of data frames to
[Music]
um
to data classes so that you can use
pedantic to validate all the rows
within a data frame and I think that's
the wrong approach pedantic is great at
what it's doing but it doesn't apply
very well to to data frames and then
Pandera is much more what we're looking
for was much more what we're looking for
it's an ex has an expressive and
flexible API it allows you to implement
checks on data frames or and it comes
also with built-in checks so you can
apply them right away on data frames and
as they say they want to do data
validation on data frames at runtime
that means
um when you initialize the data frame or
when you have a data frame and you have
a schema for example for that data frame
you can validate it using a check
against that
why
we didn't go with Pandera in the end or
why it didn't fulfill all the
requirements we had was that basically
it throws runtime exceptions but it
doesn't give you a very detailed report
on why it failed so you would have to
handle those exceptions in your feature
engineering pipelines very well
which yeah if you want to have a
production pipeline yeah that runs
continuously
um because can become quickly quite
cumbersome and also when we were looking
at it um
like a year ago there was no Pi spark
support yet but I saw actually this week
when I Was preparing this presentation
that
um they have added support for pi spark
now so you could can even
um scale out
um
those validation checks on on spark data
frames
and then last but not least
um Great Expectations is also shared in
open source package for data quality and
what we found great on this one is so it
does the data testing or data validation
but it also does documentation and
profiling and what does that mean
documentation it gives you a very
detailed report about why your data
validation failed or why it passed so
you can build a nice
monitoring tool around these reports and
give you great insight into the data
that has been written every every night
or every week into your feature store or
has been used to to feed to the models
and then also they have a nice profiling
functionality which means
um you give it a data frame
um and it will help you to figure out
um
yeah
it will help you to figure out which
expectations or data quality controls
you can actually apply to that data
frame so let's look a bit at the Core
Concepts of uh of Great Expectations
let's say you have a data frame a pandas
data frame as I said you can use a
profiler and that can actually propose
expectations to you so you run the
profiler and it will propose some
expectations that might be useful to
perform on that pandas data frame for
you so you don't have to have start from
scratch every time that's very helpful
and then basically once you have the
expectations you put them together into
an expectation suite and once you
evaluate the expectation Suite against
the data frame
um you get back these validation results
for every expectation and then
validation report for the entire
expectation Suite there's a few extra
Concepts like a data context which can
help you to encapsulate
um uh the logic to access certain data
stores together with a data source and
you also have the possibility to display
those validation reports as data docs so
as a as HTML Pages basically
thank you
um so if we have great expectations here
in um
in our input pipeline to the feature
store based on those reports we can do
two things
um first of all we can raise alerts
using the feature store so we can send
an email or select notification or pager
Duty notification to to some endpoint
but also we are going to track those
validation history or we can track those
validation reports in history so that
you can see how your data evolves over
time
um the python API is very simple
um to use it with the feature store but
in general we try to be
um yeah compatible with the native Great
Expectations apis
um so you import Great Expectations you
define the expectation Suites at your
expectations and configure them and then
you simply attach the expectation Suite
to your feature group and then every
time you insert data into your feature
group and this might be running in a
pipeline the data will be validated
before it's being written to hopsworks
so and then it will either fail with and
give you back the report so that you can
decide what to do afterwards or you can
decide if you want to write it anyway
and for example send a report and I'll
show that in a second
um
in a in a demo in a quick demo
um so
and then in in your in your feature
store or in your feature group you will
see this nice data validation history so
you can see how many how much percent of
your expectations we passed you can see
some expectations might fail due to
exceptions if they encounter
um unknown values
um but for example also numeric hello
hello mister sorry
um I just want to remind you that we are
going to have five minutes for question
and answer yeah so you have five minutes
left now for the presentation yeah thank
you I'll try to stick to it
um and then um
so for example numeric expectations you
can also see what was the actual
observed value so for example I want my
age feature to be above 18
and this expectation failed because it
observed
um a value 17.7 for example
um so then that might help you to figure
out which row or which customer it was
that actually led to that failure so
that you can investigate quickly where
the bug in your feature pipeline might
be
and now I want to show this quickly also
with some real code and you can do this
also on your own I have four minutes
five minutes left for the demo but if
you go on tinyurl.com G hopsworks you
can run this in a in a collab notebook
yourself at your in your own time and it
will guide you through the concepts of
Great Expectations and how to do data
validation on pandas data frames so you
can do it yourself
so in this case I'm just reading a very
simple
CSV file of course in a real world
scenario this would come from a data
warehouse or from an S3 bucket or
something
um I'm performing some very simple
feature engineering it's just for the
sake of the demo then you initialize
your feature group and in this case I'm
not attaching an expectation Suite yet I
I just create the feature group so that
the metadata is in is initialized and
then I want to attach the feature group
afterwards so that's often how it would
be done in development right you you
want to First Look at the data and then
build up your expectation suite and then
attach it to the feature group later so
here from this point onwards it's pure
expect great expectation code so I'm
importing the library I'm wrapping my
data frame to get GE
um pandas data frame basically and then
I can
evaluate expectations against that and
see how they perform on that data frame
so in this case I'm checking column
values to be increasing for a date time
column and as you can see
it basically if I look at the success it
failed and it also gives gives you a
partial list of why it failed so if you
would look closer at this you would see
that they are not sorted properly
basically
um you can also after I've evaluated
this expectation I can quickly create an
expectation Suite from that uh or I can
yeah create an expectation Suite Suite
for that
um I can add the previous expectation
from my validation result
um because I want to keep it it looked
good to me
um and then I can build up my
expectations with Steps step by step
like that by adding uh additional
expectations and then in the end so I
have my seven expectations I want to run
them
so I quickly run them and then I I can
look at this full report with all seven
expectations again and as you can see it
gives you a very very detailed report it
also gives you the exception why one of
the
except
expectations might have failed and so on
and it also gives you those statistics
so for example how many have been
evaluated the successful and
unsuccessful uh ones so and then I also
wanted to quickly show you the profiler
because I think it's very helpful so
there's a bunch of different one in this
one in this case I take the basic one I
take my data frame and run the profiler
against it and it basically
um in the end it includes
56 expectations
six of them failed and then you can
decide do you want to include them
anyway or not and you can basically
inspect them and see
um are they helpful are they
um yeah should I use them or should I
not use them
and then once you have your final
expectation Suite you simply take your
feature group object again and attach or
save the expectation Suite to that
feature group and in this case I'm going
to say even if it fails I want to always
ingest the data anyway
and then finally I want to write all my
data into this feature group and as you
can see when I run this it evaluated
those seven expectations and since I
said I want to always ingest
the data anyway even if it failed
as being uploaded in the end hello
[Music]
hello yeah sorry um can you hear me yeah
I can hear you I just want to I just
want to let you know that we have five
minutes left would you like to take any
questions from the audience uh I have um
a question here by
uh Francisco look Anthony I'm going to
show it now
he asked that will the pipeline break if
some expectation freeze or you run it
anyway and fix the and fix the issue
later
thank you
um so basically to answer this question
so that's exactly what I explained just
now
um you can have these two modes if you
want to fail the pipeline or you want to
write the data anyway so
um you can fail the pipeline and then
you can take your report for example and
then figure out which roads were the
ones that led to the failure and then
you might write all the other rows and
write the failing rows into some kind of
staging area so that you can have a look
later or you can completely reject the
data and not ingest it in at all so in
this case since I have configured in
always mode the data was ingested anyway
but for example I could also configure
an alert saying on data ingestion
failure
I want to send a message to a slack and
say this is critical so that then every
time some of my expectations fail
um this will be
uploaded uh will send or trigger a
message to slack and I can also go in
here afterwards and look at why these
expectations failed and that is where
Great Expectations is really good at
generating these reports
um that we can build these uis around
right so I can actually go in and see
okay which was the value on which it
failed so I can quickly figure out
um where the problem is laying
um and yeah you can at any time
um you can basically go in and
um also drop the expectations with
change the the ingestion policy for
example make it strict so that the data
gets um rejected uh when it fails and
you can also configure the expectation
Suite actually from the UI so
um you can also if you don't want to do
it in Python you can always do it here
as well using these expectation
configurations
how is the memory consumption
um so the memory consumption as far as I
know
um
this is since the data validation itself
we are not performing it or it's it's
all within great expectations so and as
far as I know
um they of course try to do the data
validation in as few passes over the
data as possible and also
um trying to use yeah
column wise operations as much as
possible so I have no precise answer to
that but I would refer you to the to the
Great Expectations Community
um to look into that I guess there are
expectation it depends on what kind of
expectations you want to run right
there's expectations that work on a row
level
um those are probably just map functions
and their expectations which require
aggregation of the whole data frame
which are probably a bit more memory
intensive